effectivement personne n'aimerait voir
un jour un avion comme celui ci le f 16
américains affronter cet autre machine
russe le sukhoï 25
ici aussi la bataille se livre à coups
de manche à balai et de remise de gaz
mais l'enjeu est strictement
commerciales en impressionne pour vendre
vadim vous présente une figure
acrobatique aux techniques
le cobra que seuls les russes savent et
peuvent réaliser cela parce que ce
biréacteur est probablement le plus
puissant du monde
pourtant les russes n'ont pratiquement
aucune chance de vendre un seul chasseur
ni même un seul hélicoptère de combat
pour la bonne raison que dans la plupart
des pays des budgets militaires sont
révisées à la baisse
personne n'achète pour vendre 60 mirage
2000 à taïwan
la france s'est pratiquement fâché avec
pékin
une situation d'autant plus difficile
pour les constructeurs aéronautiques que
l'aviation civile connaît elle aussi une
grave récession depuis la guerre du
golfe plus de mille appareils restent
cloués au sol
bien sûr il se vend toujours le même
nombre de billets mais leur prix a
baissé de plus de 10%
les compagnies civiles ont accumulé 50
milliards de francs de déficit
la célèbre paname a totalement disparu
habituellement il se vendait 1500 avions
par an à peine 300 l'an dernier alors en
attendant on peut toujours rêver debout
à des avions à double fuselage véritable
catamaran désert à des appareils de 1000
places toujours à double fuselage mais
qui décollerait sur l'eau comme des
aéroglisseurs ou à des avions soucoupe
volante capable d'évoluer à plus de 3000
km heure domaine du rêve pas sûr cette
maquette de bloc opératoire correspond
bel et bien à l'aménagement intérieur de
ce mi-26 le plus gros hélicoptère du
monde russes bien sûr
toutefois françois mitterrand venu
inaugurer le salon cet après midi en
compagnie de françois léotard n'a eu
d'yeux que pour les productions
françaises et européennes